now Emilia Clarke did you get to chat
with everyone backstage yeah kind of did
you get to talk to him yeah I just think
you're wicked it's a game of two hours
actually now is it your daughter I'm
sure you like math along to Kate
your daughter is quite the fan huge fan
she's a big friend's obsessive go and
mass are you yes Dominic you have a
relative a friend who's a fan of maths
Oh many sitting here with you and I'm
obsessed with the new job you've got
which I've really really wanted it's the
best job in the world working in the
coffee shop the woman yeah Top Gear are
you returning the favor do you watch
Game of Thrones Matt I've watched it the
first season and then I kind of fell out
of it and I tried to watch it and I
don't know what's going to see the good
bits
[Music]
what is it season six now it's bigger
than ever yeah who's laughing seriously
sounds like a chicken
I eat herbs going to stop because I
thought there's a mechanical fault
but that's a human being what's that man
there oh well I'm glad driving a nice
time I know I know
I do have one request for me though and
so would you would you be able to ask me
how I'm doing you can say no no yes well
since they you know haven't been up to
speed on the show yes thank you walked
out I went my question is it so it must
have been mentions of a sequel between
it was 1982 wasn't it when it came out
so between then and now so what why now
why not before I guess cuz Ryan wasn't
available yes
well not for 30 years but they were
waiting for me to grow up what they
decided to have to go ahead anyway
they finally yeah I came up with a good
with the story I read it and I thought
it was awesome I thought it was great
and I as I read it I read about the
character that Ryan play and I said and
I with great enthusiasm I called up the
producers I said this is great I can't
wait to get Rob and not a great park why
don't we see if we can get Ryan
and they said Oh Brian guy said why not
this is a great part for Ryan Gosling
and they said we've been talking to him
for months now wait a second
they'd only been talking to me for weeks
they probably would have gone ahead
without me no no no that's what I say
this unbelievable that Jason when you
were filming with Jennifer you did not
spot her jewelry in this scene you
didn't who here knows what that is
Oliver's is it a [__] ring obviously
yeah is it really that's what that is
that's no one her knew that that's a
good answer
did anyone suppose it doing this yes
they did
well done it everybody else kept saying
that's a really nice necklace that's
gorgeous and sudeikis of course walks
right up to me and goes is that a [__]
ring really well you've just given me
some insight into your sweet personal
life yeah all I knew what it was too
so embarrassed right now poor Olly yeah
I know what you do this to me I guess no
one told you life was gonna be this way
[Applause]
we we've been here since 5:00 across
rehearsal
you guys have been rehearsing so I guess
no one told you life is gonna be this
way so actually here's the game now I'm
not gonna say it again but if anyone
else wants to feed it into conversation
don't let me down
really good so far spoiler wouldn't the
line again oh no one ever told you life
is gonna be look at me I'm trying to
remember it though what that was gonna
be this thing become annoying
this is based on your life I mean this
is things yeah
loosely crammed things like isn't the
washing machine that happened to you
what the washing you were very hung over
oh yeah
say Tony Foster that story all that
stories are really cool though great
when I was teaching this is what this
show is based on I I went home one
weekend and I was in my 30s I was
probably 33 years of age I went home to
see my mother and then I went back and
while I was at home my mother did my
washing for me because I was only 33
back on the on the Sunday night I got
really drunk and then I went for a curry
and then the next day I went into school
I'm gonna I went into school and it was
a school in Slough and it was quite a
rough school but I had a really
brilliant hearing-impaired Department so
they were hearing impaired kids who you
know struggled they were they were
really looked after in the school anyway
I was really hung over I went there and
I bet break time I felt really
uncomfortable I thought something's not
right you know so I went to the toilet
and I pulled my trousers down and some
of my mother's knickers got I've got
mixed up in the Washington and I was
wearing my mother's
oh god no I remember going are you loser
this is such a low point you [__]
loser
the Korean food the curry and the booze
kicked in from the night before so I I
did like a fecal Jackson Pollock God not
this Jesus so I cleaned myself up I
pulled my mother's pants back went back
into the classroom and I saw one of the
hearing impaired kids they like this and
that's what I remembered that my I had a
microphone directly
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and don't answer this question if you
don't want your mother but I have don't
know why you brought this up but I did
hear you discuss you had an
extraordinary disagreement with your
wife about yourself do you know what I'm
talking about
by myself you mean yes with interest one
night as you do we were talking about
stuff and of course being circumcised I
said she said she said you're not
circumcised I said what do you mean
you've only known me a few all my life I
remember my mother telling me why
because it was fashionable at the time
she said you're not circumcised I said
that's ridiculous I should know if I'm
sorry conversation but the next day I
happened to be seeing my doctor
I was seeing my doctor for my annual
physical of course so huh while he was
down there oh by the way disagreement I
am circumcised all right because she
says I'm not and he goes down again and
he said hey I'm Jewish
I know the difference
[Laughter]
you're gonna have to change your
facebook status to movies too
[Applause]
[Music]
you